this video is sponsored by skillshare
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and not a big fan of the idea that you have
to be rich to afford good skin care products
there is a lot of misinformation
about medical grade or clinical
or professional skincare products online
you might have heard that these premium
priced products that you can usually only
get from dermatologists or skin clinics
are guaranteed to be more effective or
better or less toxic than drugstore or
so-called over-the-counter otc products that you
can get from the supermarket and from the pharmacy
you might have heard that non-medical grade
products don't provide benefits to your skin
or they're completely useless or they might even
destroy your skin this is pretty confusing because
a lot of dermatologists do recommend cheap easily
available brands that you can get at the drugstore
at the supermarket like cetaphil and cerave so
what's going on here let's talk about medical
grade skin care if you like nerding
out about the science behind beauty
products click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
firstly let's clarify we're talking about
products that are sold at these places for
you to take home and use we're not talking
about things like peels that only trained
people can use on you while you're at the clinic
we're talking about the products that are like
cleansers or serums or toners or moisturizers
that are so called medical grade or clinical
medical grade skin care products
are regulated differently
the first claim is that medical grade skin
care is regulated differently by the fda
or whatever relevant authority there is in
your particular country this isn't true in
the us the vast majority of skin care products
are regulated as cosmetics and so that means they
don't need any sort of regulatory approval or
proof of effectiveness before they get launched
and you can buy them that doesn't mean that
they're not regulated so they still have to
be safe they can't contain banned ingredients and
they still have to be stable and uncontaminated
this is the case in most places around the
world and this applies to medical grade skin
care and drugstore skin care products there's
no legal difference between the two categories
on the other hand we have drugs and when it comes
to skin care products this is over-the-counter
drugs or prescription drugs i think a lot of
the confusion comes from the use of the phrase
over-the-counter people promoting medical grade
skin care products often use this term to describe
products that you buy at the
drugstore and they say that
over-the-counter products are less
effective than medical grade products
in drug regulation over-the-counter has a legal
meaning it refers to drugs that you can buy
without a prescription and so over-the-counter
drugs are actually more strictly regulated than
most medical grade skin care over-the-counter
drugs include things like sunscreen aspirin
benzoyl peroxide cream and antihistamines
this is in contrast to a prescription drug
where you need to have a prescription from an
appropriately authorized health professional
like a doctor before you're allowed to buy it both
over-the-counter drugs and prescription drugs need
to be approved before they're allowed to be sold
and part of that approval process is showing
that it is effective there are also different
standards for how drugs need to be manufactured
compared to cosmetics products that are regulated
as drugs will be clearly labeled so in the us for
example there's the drug facts panel in australia
there will be the AUST R or the AUST L number
as well as the concentrations of
the active ingredients on the front
in some countries like japan and korea there's
also the quasi-drug or cosmeceutical category
and that's also regulated a bit differently from
both drugs and cosmetics but again that will
also be clearly labeled but with medical grade
products unless they are actually a drug there's
no legal requirement for that sort of labeling
certain legal terms there's no difference between
medical grade and regular skin care products
both can be regulated as cosmetics or drugs
usually there's actually less drugs in medical
grade skin care than you can get at a drugstore
so over-the-counter skin care drugs include things
like sunscreen benzoyl peroxide creams adapalene
salicylic acid and you can find most of
these in both medical grade and regular
skincare lines but the majority of medical grade
skin care products are cosmetics and that means
they're less regulated in terms of their efficacy
than over-the-counter drug skin care products if
you want to go straight for the most effective
stuff you can get prescription only tazarotene
and tretinoin creams and you won't find these
in medical grade skin care lines you get these
literally at the drugstore there's rigorous
testing and research behind medical grade skin
care products they use higher quality ingredients
then there's a myth that there's always rigorous
research and testing that goes into making medical
grade skin care products but not normal skin care
products and the idea that they use higher grade
ingredients but medical grade professional and
clinical aren't regulated terms and so there is
zero guarantee of this some medical grade brands
will do rigorous testing and clinical studies but
anyone can slap the words medical grade on their
products and decide to only sell through skin
clinics and there are lots of regular drugstore
skin care products that have rigorous testing
and clinical studies as well some of the ones
that are regulated as drugs like sunscreen will
have to go through mandatory clinical studies
a lot of the more dermatologist-friendly brands
like cerave qv and bioderma will have done lots
and lots of clinical studies on their products as
well even the really large mass market brands that
a lot of people promoting medical grade products
tend to diss like olay and neutrogena they
conduct a lot of clinical studies and scientific
research that goes into making their products
olay are responsible for a lot of the
information we know about niacinamide
in skin care neutrogena do a lot of
studies on sunscreens and both of
these brands publish a lot of their research
in leading peer-reviewed scientific journals
on the other hand it's really rare that
you see a medical grade skincare brand
publish peer-reviewed scientific research
they contain higher percentages of actives
they're allowed to penetrate deeper than
over-the-counter and drugstore products
there are also these myths about the effectiveness
of the products so medical grade skin care
products are supposedly allowed to put in higher
concentrations of actives or they're allowed to
penetrate deeper into the skin and so the deeper
it goes the bigger the effect it can have but
again this is a myth because medical grade has no
legal meaning so there's no regulatory difference
and so there's nothing that they are allowed to
do that regular skin care isn't allowed to do
you can get really high percentages
of actives from brands like paula's
choice in the ordinary and these are
definitely not medical grade skincare
i think the myth of medical grade skin care
products being the one true skincare that
we should all be using is mostly perpetuated by
people who have good intentions but they've been
fed the wrong information by brands who are either
being dishonest or should really know better and
that's okay we've all fallen for marketing myths
before they can be really convincing especially
if they're coming from someone who appears to be
really authoritative and knowledgeable but there's
also a small but very vocal group of people online
who are using these myths to bully and shame
people they're shaming people for not being rich
enough to be able to afford these products or not
wanting to spend more on these products because
supposedly they don't care about their skin enough
they're bullying people for being so stupid to
think that drugstore products can actually work
and they're fearmongering about drugstore products
ruining people's skin a lot of the time these
people are also selling medical grade skincare
products and all of this is really not okay
i'm not saying that medical grade products
are bad or they're not worth the price
a lot of them are really good and a
lot of clinical brands do invest in
research and hiring scientists who can
make their formulations really effective
ultraceuticals is one of my favorite skincare
brands because they put a lot of effort into
making their products really effective and
they're in the clinical category but that's
not the case with all medical grade skin care
brands and there are a lot of drugstore brands
that also take this sort of approach medical
grade skincare is just like any other type
of skin care whether it's good or effective
or worth the price or if they have clinical
studies to back up their effects has to be judged
on a brand by brand or a product by product basis
there are plenty of drugstore products that work
really well and so you can build an effective
skincare routine on a budget you can also build
an effective routine with more expensive medical
grade products so it's perfectly fine to use
and promote medical grade skincare products
it's not okay to promote them using myths or to
harass people who aren't using these products
and if you sell medical grade skincare products
you shouldn't be using these myths to promote
your products anyway deceptive marketing is
illegal and people who have been deceived
tend not to be very happy about it afterwards
if a product is honestly amazing you don't have
to puff it up with myths about fda regulation or
how deep they can go into your skin or how toxic
drugstore products are if a product has completely
transformed your skin or transformed your client's
skin then just say that that on its own
is very convincing marketing if there's an
amazing team of researchers and formulators
who have contributed to making this product
if there are really good before and after photos
if it has actives that you rarely find in other
products then again just say those things so
those are my thoughts on medical grade skin care
do you use medical grade skin care have
you also seen these myths floating around
let me know in the comments and if
there's a myth i've missed out on
thanks to today's video sponsor skillshare
they sponsor a lot of educational content
on youtube skillshare is an online community
that has thousands of classes on a huge range
of topics like design web development marketing
and analytics i take all of my instagram photos
on my phone and i recently switched from
android to iphone and so i've had to re-learn
a lot of my processes so i decided to go and
properly learn how to do phone photography
the class i took was iphone photography how to
take pro photos on your iphone by dale mcmanus
this actually isn't just specific to iphones
dale goes through photo composition and the
most useful thing i found was learning how to
use the free version of lightroom in the past
i was uploading my photos from my phone onto
my laptop so i could edit it with photoshop
and then re-download them back onto my
phone to post and so it was really cool
to learn how to use a few extra features on
my phone so i could skip all that transferring
if you want to check out skillshare the
first thousand people to click the link in
the description we'll get a free trial of
the premium membership for a limited time
it's normally less than $10 a month with a
yearly subscription i hope you liked this
video if you did you can click the like and the
subscribe you can also follow me on instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience and check out my blog for
more sciencey nerdy beauty talk see you next time